conference I'm joined on stage by
President Lagarde
and vice president de guindos
my name is Wolfgang croisel as we are
connected via video to some who are
connected on screen I would like to ask
you to put on turn on your camera and
your microphones if you ask questions
later on and with that I give the floor
to president McCart
thank you very much so good afternoon
the vice president and I welcome you to
our press conference
inflation is projected to remain too
high for too long
therefore the governing Council today
decided to increase the three key ECB
interest rates by 50 basis points in
line with our determination to ensure
the timely return of inflation to our
two percent medium-term Target
the elevated level of uncertainty
reinforces the importance of a data
dependent approach to our policy rate
decisions
which will be determined
by our assessment of the inflation
Outlook in light of the incoming
economic and financial data
the Dynamics of underlying inflation
and the strength of monetary policy
transmission
we are monitoring current market
tensions closely
and stand ready to respond as necessary
to preserve price stability and
financial stability in the Euro area
the Euro area banking sector is
resilient with strong capital and
liquidity positions
in any case
our policy toolkit is fully equipped to
provide liquidity support to the euro
area Financial system if needed
and to preserve the smooth transmission
of monetary policy
the new ECB staff macroeconomic
projections were finalized in early
March
before the recent emergence of financial
Market tensions
as such these tensions imply additional
uncertainty around the Baseline
assessments of inflation and growth
prior to these latest developments the
Baseline path for headline inflation had
already been revised down mainly owing
to a smaller contribution from Energy
prices than previously expected
ECB staff now sees inflation averaging
5.3 percent in 23
2.9 percent in 24 and 2.1 percent in 25.
at the same time
underlying price pressures remain strong
inflation excluding energy and food
continued to increase in February
and ECB staff expects it to average 4.6
percent in 23
Which is higher than foreseen in the
December projections
subsequently it is projected to come
down to 2.5 percent in 24
and 2.2 percent in 25. as the upward
pressures from past Supply shocks and
the reopening of the economy Fade Out
and has tighter monetary policy
increasingly dampens demand
the Baseline projections for growth in
23 have been revised up to an average of
one percent as a result of both the
decline in Energy prices and the
economy's greater resilience to the
challenging International environment
CB staff then expect growth to pick up
further to 1.6 percent in both 24 and 25
underpinned by a robust labor market
improving confidence
and a recovery in real incomes
at the same time the pickup in growth in
24 and 25 is weaker than projected in
December owing to the tightening of
monetary policy
the decisions taken today are set out in
a press release that is available on our
website
I will now outline in more details how
we see the economy and inflation
developing
and will then explain our assessment of
Financial and monetary conditions
turning to the economic activity first
the Euro area economy stagnated in the
fourth quarter of 22 thus avoiding the
previously expected contraction
however private domestic demand fell
sharply
High inflation prevailing uncertainties
and Tighter financing conditions dented
private consumption and investment which
fell by 0.9 percent and 3.6 percent
respectively
under the Baseline the economy looks set
to recover over the coming quarters
industrial production should pick up as
Supply conditions improve further
confidence continues to recover
and firms work off large order backlogs
Rising wages
and falling Energy prices will partly
offset the loss of purchasing power that
many households are experiencing as a
result of high inflation
this in turn will support consumer
spending
moreover the labor market remains strong
despite the weakening of economic
activity
employment grew by 0.3 percent in the
fourth quarter of 22 and the
unemployment rate stayed at its
historical low of 6.6 in January 23.
government measures
to Shield the economy from the impact of
high energy prices
should be temporary targeted and
tailored to preserving incentives to
consume less energy
as Energy prices fall and risks around
the energy Supply recede it is important
to start rolling back these measures
promptly and in a concerted manner
measures falling short of these
principles are likely to drive up
medium-term inflation pressures which
would call for a stronger monetary
policy response
moreover in line with the eu's economic
governance framework
and as stated in the European
commission's guidance of March 8 23
fiscal policies should be oriented
towards making our economy more
productive
and gradually bringing down high public
debt
policies to enhance the EUR area's
Supply capacity especially in the energy
sector can help reduce price pressures
in the medium term
to that end governments should swiftly
implement the investment and structural
reform plans under the Next Generation
EU program
the reform of the eu's economic
governance framework should be concluded
rapidly
let's look at inflation
inflation edged down to 8.5 percent in
February
the decline resulted from A Renewed
sharp drop in Energy prices
by contrast food price inflation
increased further to 15 percent
with the past surge in the cost of
energy and of other inputs for food
production still feeding through to
Consumer prices
moreover underlying price pressures
remain strong
inflation excluding energy and food
increased to 5.6 in February and other
indicators of underlying inflation have
also stayed High
non-energy industrial goods
inflation Rose to 6.8 percent in
February mainly reflecting the delayed
effects of past Supply bottlenecks and
high energy prices
Services inflation which rose to 4.8
percent in February
is also still being driven by the
gradual pass-through of past energy cost
increases
pent-up demand from the reopening of the
economy and Rising wages
wage pressures have strengthened on the
back of robust labor markets and
employees aiming to recoup some of the
purchasing power lost owing to high
inflation
moreover many firms were able to raise
their profit margins in sectors faced
with constrained supply and resurgent
demand
at the same time most measures of
longer-term inflation expectations
currently stand at around two percent
although they warrant continued
monitoring especially in light of recent
volatility in market-based inflation
expectations
moving to the risk assessment now
risks to the outlook for economic growth
are tilted to the downside
persistently elevated Financial Market
tensions could tighten broader credit
conditions more strongly than expected
and dampen confidence
Russia's unjustified war against Ukraine
and its people
continues to be a significant downside
risk to the economy and could again push
up the cost of energy and food
there could also be an additional drug
on Euro area growth if the world economy
weakened more sharply than expected
however companies could adapt more
quickly to the challenging International
environment and together with the fading
out of the energy shock this could
support higher growth than currently
expected
the upside risks to inflation include
existing pipeline pressures that could
still send retail prices even higher
than expected in the near term
domestic factors such as a persistent
right in inflation expectations above
our Target are higher than anticipated
increases in wages and profit margins
to drive inflation higher including over
the medium term
moreover a stronger than expected
economic Rebound in China could give a
fresh boost to commodity prices and
foreign demand
the downside risk to inflation include
persistently elevated Financial Market
tensions that could accelerate
disinflation
in addition falling Energy prices could
translate into reduced pressure from
underlying inflation and wages
a weakening of demand including owing to
a stronger deceleration of bank credit
or a stronger than projected
transmission of monetary policy would
also contribute to lower price pressures
none currently anticipated
especially over the medium term
so let's look at financial and market
conditions
Market interest rates Rose considerably
in the weeks following our last meeting
but the increase has strongly reversed
over recent days
in a context of severe Financial Market
tensions
Bank credit to your area firms has
become more expensive
credit to firms has weakened further
owing to lower demand and Tighter credit
Supply conditions
household borrowing has become more
expensive as well especially owing to
higher mortgage rates
this rise in borrowing costs and the
resultant decline in demand
along with tighter credit standards
have led to a further slowdown in the
growth of loans to households
and these weaker loan Dynamics
money growth has slowed sharply driven
by its most liquid component
so summing up
inflation is projected to remain too
high for too long
therefore the governing Council today
decided to increase the three key ECB
interest rates by 50 basis points
in line with our determination to ensure
that timely return of inflation to our
two percent medium-term Target
the elevated level of uncertainty
reinforces the importance of a
data-dependent approach to our policy
rate decisions
which will be determined by our
assessment of inflation Outlook
in light of the incoming economic and
financial data
the Dynamics of underlying inflation
and the strength of monetary policy
transmission
we are monitoring current market
tensions closely
and stand ready to respond as necessary
to preserve price stability and
financial stability in the Euro area
in any case we stand ready to adjust all
of our instruments within our mandate to
ensure that inflation returns to our
medium-term Target and to preserve the
smooth functioning of monetary policy
transmission
we now stand ready to take your
questions
and the first question goes to Alex
Weber of Bloomberg News Alex please
thank you good afternoon I was wondering
could you explain a little bit how you
see the path for interest rates ahead I
mean in the um until a few days ago it
seemed pretty clear that interest rates
would have to rise further after this
meeting but you didn't give any guidance
in the statement and does this mean it
could be that we've already reached the
peak in interest rates and then secondly
on regarding the banking sector more
broadly a lot of people have drawn
parallels to
um between what happened at Credit
Suisse and Silicon Valley Bank between
and um
failures we've seen at the last
financial crisis like bear stones and do
you see any risks that were on the verge
of this demo crisis like in 2008
thank you very much for your uh for your
question
um on on your first question
I would call your attention to one
particular paragraph which is the first
one in our monetary policy statement in
which we are really trying to dissect
for you
the mechanism of our reaction function
and this is really the best guidance
that we can provide
and it is number one the assessment of
the inflation Outlook in light of the
incoming economic and financial data
number two the Dynamics of underlying
inflation and number three the strength
of our monetary policy transmission
so that's brand new
these three components we never
discussed them we never let them out and
they are clearly identified as the three
elements that will be taken into account
to determine our reaction function going
forward
second point
if our Baseline
was to persist
when the uncertainty reduces
we know that we have a lot more ground
to cover
okay
but it's a big caveat if our Baseline
was to persist
as you know
the projection that were
decided by staff sorry not decided but
determined by staff
um
are based on data and assessment of the
situation with the cutoff date
and that cutoff date was February 15th
for the international Outlook and
Technical assumptions and March 1st for
the Euro area macroeconomic projections
now since March the 1st a lot obviously
has developed
and
it is
it the protections that we have do not
incorporate any of the most recent
development and certainly not the impact
of the most recent
Financial tensions that we have observed
on the markets
so there is a level of uncertainty that
has been completely elevated as a result
of that and that is the reason why we
reinforce the principle of data
dependency
that we have indicated in the past with
a clear map of the reaction function
that we will have in the future
so it it does it is not possible at this
point in time and on the basis of the
first component that I have mentioned
which is assessment of the inflation
Outlook in light of the incoming
economic and financial data
it is not possible to determine at this
point in time you know what the path
will be going forward
but we know that it will be data
dependent and we know that if the
Baseline as we have it was confirmed and
was to persist we would have more ground
to cover
on your second Point
um
I will again read for you one more time
what is in the second paragraph This
time of our monetary policy statement
which is that we are monitoring current
market tensions closely
We Stand ready to respond as necessary
to preserve price stability and
financial stability in the Euro area
and given
the reforms that have taken place and I
was around in 2008 so I have clear
recollection of what happened and what
we had to do
we did reform the framework we did agree
on Basel III we did increase the capital
ratio we did increase the financial
coverage ratio as well and I think that
the banking sector is currently in a
much much stronger position than where
it was back in 2008.
added to which
if it was needed
we do have the tools we do have the
facilities
that are available and we also have a
toolbox that has other instruments that
we always stand ready to activate if and
when needed and finally and that's a
tribute to our staff because as you can
imagine we all have worked quite hard in
the last few days and particularly the
last few hours they have demonstrated in
the past that they can also exercise
creativity in very short order
in case it is needed to respond to what
would be a liquidity crisis if there was
such a thing but this is not what we are
seeing
thank you
thank you president and the next
question goes to an alternative to
remote participants to Balaji colony of
Reuters apology please over to you
good afternoon and thank you for taking
my questions uh president could you
unpack for me what you mean a lot more
Grand to cover
um
can you repeat the first part I missed
it
yes yes I said could you please unpack
for me your statement that there might
be a lot more ground to cover should the
uh the Baseline Prevail what does that
mean especially given that prior to this
meeting
almost all governing council members
including Philip Blaine has said that
more rate hikes will likely be needed
Beyond March so are you walking back on
that commitment or is the is the ecb's
inflation fighting um
um
stamina weaning are you giving up on
inflation the second is second question
I have is the the usual one I'm sorry uh
what other options were being discussed
in the meeting today what were the
Alternatives uh that policy makers were
supporting
question
uh
are not waning
bite inflation and we are determined to
return inflation back to two percent
Target in the medium term
that should not be doubted the
determination is intact and the
the path at which we will
cover the ground the pace that we will
take will be entirely data dependent
that's what we have always said
and we are saying on this specific
occasion that given the level of
uncertainty that has been significantly
increased as a result of the most recent
Financial tensions and development given
that level of uncertainty
it is better to make the decision that
we believe is a robust decision
with our 50 basis points increase
and then see what the data tell us and
what next assessment we make on the
basis of that data but let me reassure
you
we are determined to fight inflation and
return it to two percent and we will
take the measures that are necessary
there will be data dependent and they
will function on the basis of these
three parameters that I have just
mentioned to illustrate what our
reaction function is
you had a second question which you said
would a repeat of previous questions
which I think had to do with any other
options what has happened behind those
closed doors and I fully appreciate the
question
I have to tell you that the executive
board proposed that
option which is described in the
monetary policy statement and that no
other option was proposed I can also
tell you that the decision was adopted
by a very large majority
with three or four that did not support
the decision not in its principle
because
they were ready to go for that decision
but they were Keen to probably give a
bit more time
to see how the situation unfolds and
what additional data we can collect but
otherwise it was a very large majority
decision
and I would say taken in
a rather record time
thank you
thank you president the guard
um I would like to now turn to
kolyaruccio of the German weekly edit
site cool yeah please
I would like to ask a question
concerning the data driven decisions
um isn't there a conflict of goals
between price stability and financial
stability and
to what extent
do you consider slowing down the pace of
of rate hikes because of financial
stability do you have to slow it down
perhaps because of financial stability
that is my first question and the second
um
were you surprised by the financial
by the financial problems we saw we see
now in the US and we saw last year in
the Pension funds in the UK was this a
surprise or is this something which was
expected perhaps by by monetary policy
experts
well let me be pretty clear on that
point as well I believe that there is no
trade-off between price stability and
financial stability and I think that
if anything with this decision we are
demonstrating this
we are addressing the price stability
issue by raising interest rate by 50
basis points which is what we had
intended
and because inflation is projected to
remain way above our Target and for too
long
and separate from that we also are
monitoring Market tensions
We Stand ready to provide any kind of
additional facilities if needed
uh we do have extensive facilities more
so by the way than than the FED in terms
of size of the collateral pools and and
uh and and facilities and we can do more
if necessary we have demonstrated that
uh in the times of Pep all the
instruments that we decided in the pep
times whether it is uh on on the the
pool of collateral where the collaterals
whether it's on the uh on the haircuts
whether it's on on all issues uh that
can be reactivated like that and we
always stand ready to use them again
so you know Euro liquidity is perfectly
addressed no issue on that front so the
the there's no trade-off
we have to do our job this is primary
objective price stability and as I said
in the identification of the three
components that we will that will inform
our decision that will determine our
reaction function you find the word
Financial if you if you look carefully
you have assessment of the inflation
Outlook in light of the incoming
economic and financial data so the
financial issues are captured in order
to assess inflation so there is no there
is no trade-off we have Financial
stability very much uh in as part of of
our our radar screen and the tools that
we can deploy but there is no trade-off
between the two
you had did you want to add to that vice
president well uh well first of all good
afternoon
well from a financial stability
standpoint and the perspective is quite
clear if you look at the industry as a
whole as the president has indicated
before you know the situation of the of
the of the European Banks they are
resilient
capital is much higher than it was 10 15
years ago before the the global
financial crisis the liquidity position
of the European Banks is robust
if you look at the liquidity ratios on
average they are clearly above the
minimum requirements and even the
pandemic levels
and if even if you look at the
composition of these of these liquidity
buffers they are high quality very high
liquidity assets so it's in that respect
the composition is quite quite positive
and finally there is something that I
think that is relevant is you know the
increasing interest rates
well it's positive in terms of the
margins of the European Banks and this
Improvement in terms of profitability
more than offsets you know potential
losses in fixing and portfolios
looking at the exposure for instance to
you know to create Swiss they are quite
Limited
and you know there is no consideration
there is no a single party that
concentrates a large part of that that
exposure and finally as the president
has indicated well we have a toolkit of
instruments just in case that are needed
in order to deliver liquidity
thank you vice president and now the
next question for Martin Arnold of the
financial times Martin please
foreign
could you uh just explore a bit more
this potential for a trade-off between
Financial stability and price stability
um could you foresee a situation where
given the outlook for inflation you need
to raise rates further but there's a
risk that that could trigger a financial
crisis or make a financial stress worse
second question is that given
um given that you've said the underlying
inflation is is going to be one of the
key factors you look at when deciding
one of the three key factors does that
mean that until you see an easing of
most of the indicators of underlying
inflation which you'll not see at the
moment you won't be able to stop raising
rates thank you
thank you Martin for your questions the
two questions
on the first one as I said earlier we
don't see any trade-off between
price stability and financial stability
and we will address each of these two
with their respective uh instrument
for the moment interest rates for Price
stability and the set of facilities that
we have available additional lines if
necessary including in other currencies
if that is needed in order to address uh
Financial stability issues so
they inform each other I'll come to that
in a second but we handle them
separately and there is no trade-off
between the two
it's pretty obvious when I say that the
inflation Outlook will be assessed in
light of the incoming economic and
financial data that the financial data
whatever they are will inform our
assessment of inflation so through that
assessment sorry through that those
financial data we actually take into
account development in the financial
markets uh financing Financial cost
terms and conditions and the financing
of the economy at Large
use second question
had to do if I recall with the my second
sorry wait a minute I need to get back
to the uh the my second item yeah
because you did refer to the key but
it's the second the first one that we
mentioned is the assessment of inflation
Outlook in light of Economic and
financial data and it needs to be
confirmed by the underlying component of
inflation
and on that front we are again going to
be data dependent
and it is obvious that as long as we see
um
underlying component of inflation going
up
this is not going to stop
our fight against inflation so we will
need to receive confirmation on the
underlying component of
inflation we will need to receive
confirmation that we are heading in the
direction of our Target of two percent
we are seeing some slight uh Improvement
in certain areas but frankly not a lot
and we know that whether you look at
core which is one of the components of
the underlying inflation
um
or whether we look at you know other
dissection of inflation and in
particular whether when we look at
Services
um it's it's
not yet heading in the direction that
would confirm uh the uh inflation
Outlook that we have
thank you president and the next
question goes to Isabella bufaki of
insolar
Isabella please
thank you for the opportunity good
afternoon my question is are you in real
life not on screen
thank you
um my question is on the mentioning of
monetary policy transmission which comes
in your decisions in the three
um
the the three points that you said about
uh is explaining your reaction function
so one of them is the monetary policy
transmission and also at the end of your
decisions uh you mentioned that you the
company council is ready to adopt the
and adjust the uh your instruments to
preserve uh also the monetary policy
transmission so we think about TPI when
we we hear about this and I like to know
whether you think that TPI can be used
when banking tensions start to
jeopardize the transmission of monetary
policy and if whether in you're a fully
equipped toolkit you could also consider
to adjust the pace of the reduction of
the Holdings of Securities under the
asset purchase program so the QT
foreign
first of all on on monetary policy
transmission I
I will be giving a speech soon
about monetary policy transmission and
about the first leg of monetary policy
transmission and the second leg of
monetary policy transmission all I can
say at this point in time is that we're
beginning to see transmission of our
monetary policy through the credit
Channel and if you look at at rates if
you look at terms and conditions if you
look at the impact that it has on the
demand of financing on the part of both
corporates and households we are
beginning to see transmission of our
monetary policy which is really which is
which is you know what we what we
expected
API
um
transmission
policy instrument was precisely designed
to make sure that monetary policy would
travel and move all the way to all
members of the 20 member states sorry to
all 20 members of the Euro area
and that would and that would be caused
by
factors that had nothing to do with the
fundamentals of an economy or its
general
macroeconomic policies
we have not yet had to decide whether
Financial tensions would qualify in that
respect but it could be the case I'm I'm
advancing a little bit because we did
not discuss that at all and it's
something that would need to be debated
with the governing Council nor did we
decide anything on the partial
reinvestment under the app that's a
principle that we decided back at our
February meeting which has been in place
now as of the 1st of March and that will
continue to unfold in a in a regular and
unimpended fashion
turning back to our remote participants
I would like now to give the floor to
jean-philippe La cour of page please
yes yes now you can hear me and see me I
hope
okay good good afternoon
um one question on this underlying
components of inflation you mentioned do
you put the significant contribution of
profit margins into these components
because the profit margin seems to
develop well and that could maybe put
some questions on The Narrative of the
ECB very focused on the risk either on
the wage price Loop and I would like to
hear what you think about this
contribution of corporate profits to to
to to inflation
um and a second question if I may
um Mr Windows you are quoted that some
banks may be very memorable you would
have told this to
um ministers briefed earlier this week I
don't hear this today in your statement
maybe you can
precise or confirm or not what has been
reported thank you
thank you very much for your two
questions and
I just want to
go back to the statement
I just want to find the right sentence
where for the first time actually we
talk about margins
and and and it is
must be in the inflation sections
anyway I'm not going to waste your time
trying to find the sentence in which we
uh oh here it is so moreover many firms
were able to raise their profit margins
in sectors faced with constrained supply
and resurgent demand
so
we mention it very specifically it is
part of the analysis that we conduct as
has been mentioned by by some of you who
are following us very carefully we had a
retreat of all the governors of the
governing Council to discuss in-depth
various matters one of which was
actually the various components that
fuel underlying inflation and we did
have some assessment of the increase in
in margins by the corporates which
played a role
I'd like to say one thing because there
has also been reference to the fact that
I would have mentioned the word wages x
times during my last press conference
I think what we hope for is
a proper burden sharing of what really
is a quasi-tax
this cost push shock has been operating
a bit like like attacks at least in in
portion of its form and that this tax
should be shared because there has to be
some burden sharing what we are
concerned about is
whatever the burden sharing if that was
to spiral into the second round effect
that we don't want to see frankly
but this burden sharing aspect is
something that needs to be debated as
Society level at corporate level and and
there's certainly something that we
would we would welcome to the extent
that it reduces the risk of second round
effect in particular on the other
question that you asked frankly I also
want to uh point to you the sentence
which is in the second paragraph of the
monetary policy statement and as you
know the first paragraphs matter and in
there we say the Euro area banking
sector is resilient with strong capital
and liquidity positions and we stand by
that statement strongly but I will let
you vice president comment on this on
this wonderful leak
as you can imagine you know I remember
what I told the ministers is almost
identical to what I have just told you
so that the banks are resilient
High Capital ratios
robust liquidity buffers high quality of
the pain components of the liquidity
buffer
limited exposure to the institutions of
the US in that case because it was last
Tuesday uh
of the of the US
and simultaneously in that you know the
overall assessment was quite clear
so that you know the banking industry in
Europe is musliment
thank you vice president Madam president
next question goes to Andres should of
expansion Android space
good afternoon Madam president when you
talk about creativity of the staff do
you think that if needed DCB could come
up with a tool like the one presented by
the Federal Reserve accepting bonds like
at par instead of market value or would
face legal constraints
and I have a second question if I may
you have visited this pain recently and
I'm sure you are aware that there's a
concern about the low remuneration on
the deposits there Banks say that this
is because they have plenty of liquidity
from the ECB so I was wondering if you
think that the low deposits are going to
continue until TLT arose mature or it is
something different and you are not in
the same point as the banks thank you
but thank you um
thank you for your two questions so
when I say that I have full confidence
in staff creativity what I mean is that
I have seen them in action they've been
there they've done it and on the
occasion of kovid for instance they were
able in very short order to put together
programs that proved extremely efficient
in order to resist the downside effect
of the crisis
so those tools exist they are strong
they are powerful and they can be
reactivated anytime we always stand
ready to do that
um added to which the facilities that we
have currently are probably broader and
more accessible than the ones that
pre-existed at the Fed
so I don't see the need at this point in
time to explore
any alternatives to the tools that we
have because I think that they function
if it was needed at some point in time
of course I know stuff will will stand
up to the occasion and will also look at
what can be done within our mandate and
in accordance with the rules of the
treaty under which we are governed
on the issue of
remuneration of deposits I have spoken
my mind on Spanish television
and and I have observed that in quite a
few countries now uh the the dfr is
taken into account in order to determine
the rate at which deposits are
remunerated either deposited site or
term deposits and that's obviously this
is something that needs to be debated
between the clients and their Banks but
I observe that there are quite a few
countries where Banks actually do that
and competition between them is
facilitating that process
the next question goes to Ashley Nelson
of the New York Times special please
hi good afternoon
um
you I would like to go back to this
point about the incoming economic and
financial data I mean in the past
meetings we've heard a lot about what
the economic data is the underlying
inflation data could you detail a little
more what the financial data is that
you'll be watching and is there a new
emphasis on this data or is has it
always kind of been there and then my
second question is how much has the
volatility we've seen in Bank stocks
recently as the meeting was happening
affected today's decision not
necessarily the interest rate decision
but the choice to not kind of lay the
path ahead more clearly thank you
I like your last word clearly
this is something that we are longing
for clarity
um because the the obviously we we work
on the basis of data of observations of
uh facts and and there is currently for
the reasons that I have mentioned in my
monetary policy statement a degree of
uncertainty that pre-existed but that
has certainly been Amplified by the most
recent Financial tensions that we have
observed in the last few days so that
that has you know it's obviously
difficult for a group of 26
members of the governing Council to come
to a decision in in the face of
projection and the first of the three
elements that I have mentioned
to determine our reaction function to
come up to a decision but we were
certainly confident that this 50
basis points rate increase was a robust
decision considering the ground that
needs to be covered
what financial data do we look at
we are particularly concerned obviously
about our monetary policy transmission
so we look very carefully using various
analytical tools we look at credit
credit to corporates credit to
households terms and conditions
um
restrictions eventually if if they were
to to be observed to assess whether the
financial conditions are are tightening
and what the impact this tightening of
financial conditions will then have on
the economy those are the key key
components that we we assess to
determine our monetary policy
transmission
thank you president and the next
question going back to our remote
participant goes to Tom Fairless of the
Wall Street Journal Tom please
Tom can you hear us
this does not seem to be the case then I
would give the next question to Eric
Albert of lemond also connected via
video call
Eric Eric please
good afternoon thank you very much for
taking the question
um there's been a lot of parallels done
with 2008 obviously the banks are in
different circumstances but in July 2008
the ECB increase in interest rate data
interest rate hike just two months
before the biggest financial crash in
recent history is the CB at risk of
doing the same mistake uh first thing
and the second question is about the
transmission of military policy it takes
a long time for interest right uh
interest rate hikes to go through the
economy
given their uncertainty isn't there a
case for at least slowing down you said
you were data dependent but it's another
case now to slow down in the next few
meetings
thank you very much for your two
questions
um
as you you said yourself
um the banks are in a completely
different position from 2008. and you
know crisis are never exactly the same
anyway but the architecture of our
banking system the framework within
which they operate the supervision that
is applied to the banking system have
been all considerably improved
so obviously we're mindful of our
history and what has been done in the
past but we are all confident that the
decision that we made today is a robust
decision was called for was needed and
and
we have as you have noticed I'm sure
indicated uh very precisely that as to
the future we would be data dependent
and that I think is predicated on the
fact that we need to have a better
assessment once the financial tensions
on the market uh Abate in in in in the
future
on you second question we are seeing
a relative we're beginning to see
a good transmission of our monetary
policy in in the credit sector as as I
have mentioned earlier on I think we
have seen a reduction of
um several basis points 20 to 16 basis
points depending on whether you look at
corporates or households increase in the
credit rates that are offered and a
significant tightening on the part of
the banks that are probably assessing
and reassessing the risks that they're
taking so this this is in our view the
beginning of an indication of good
transmission of monetary policy this is
not the end of it as you said it takes a
a longer time
it seems to to have transmitted rather
rapidly if you consider that we decided
to to normalize our monetary policy back
in December a year ago so it's a little
over a year ago and we are certainly
beginning to see in the credit segment
uh the impact of our decisions are we
seeing dampening demand that that
remains to be seen and how much more
need does it need to be dampened in
order to meet the uh the objectives that
that we have which is two percent
medium-term Target to be seen we are
data dependent we're going to really uh
look at
the uncertainty fading out hopefully and
what projections we will be able to
operate upon as well as what assessment
we can make at our next policy meetings
in May June and subsequently
thank you madam let's try again with Tom
Fairless of the Wall Street Journal Tom
can you connect
aye aye can you hear me yes
okay
um so thanks thanks so much for taking
my question
um I I
suppose the first question is
um we've started to see these signs of
weakness in financial markets and uh you
haven't taken that as a reason to pause
but is there do you think a message in
what's happening it's something that we
haven't seen for a while and that has
reminiscent you know
um it kind of brings back memories of uh
maybe to the the financial crisis as
other people have said
um I mean it's just the unusualness of
this a reason to kind of think twice
about about future rate increases do you
think you know with this this phrase
that we hear
um you know
um uh raise rates until something breaks
and my second question
um was was related that
um at the moment that so the bank
failures were in the US do you think
this is more of a U.S Pacific issue do
you think there's a there's something
fundamentally different about Europe
that means uh European banks are less
less vulnerable or the level maybe the
level of your policy rate means they're
less vulnerable thank you
thank you very much for your two
questions um on the on the first
question you know I would like to just
reiterate our confidence in in our
banking sector as I said earlier on it's
a banking sector that is resilient that
is as strong capital and liquidity
positions and we are monitoring uh the
particular situation and we are
monitoring the market tensions and we
stand ready to respond with all the
tools that we have that can be switched
on and by any tools that would need to
be applied to the situation depending on
the circumstances so we are not it's not
business as usual but we believe that
the decision that we have taken is
robust is completely justified by the
circumstances and informed by our
current analysis
um is it a U.S specific problem
you know we we are all governed by well
we are the banking sector is governed by
Basel III and banks operate within the
framework of Basel III as you know there
have been multiple discussions and and
and disagreement as to who applies Basel
three better than the other but I would
simply observe because comparisons are
are pretty odious that in Europe
we have strong supervision
we have strong capital and we have solid
liquidity positions
and as the vice president said exposures
are not concentrated and based on the
work that has been conducted by the SSM
we don't have similar occurrence as the
one that occurred in California for
instance but maybe vice president you
want to add to that well perhaps you
know the only thing to to add is that
the business model of the Silicon Valley
Bank was quite unique
and that it was you know there was a
mismatch
between the assets and the liabilities
and that you know it made this Bank
vulnerable and this has been indicated
by the American authorities to any
important change in interest rates
thank you vice president president and
the last question today goes to Leonidas
Excellence leaders of handles blood the
latest please thank you good afternoon I
have a question concerning the excess of
liquidity and the ecv balance sheet did
you discuss about an increase in the
level of reduction and if yes when could
this increase start thank you thank you
so much you give me a chance to be very
brief in my response no we did not
discuss
we had plenty to discuss today and we
did not discuss that particular one
thank you thank you very much this
concludes our press conference our next
press conference is on the 4th of May
until the all the best and have a good
afternoon